i don't think i ever became competitive
actually until
i was 88 uh-huh
and i got right
place in what they call the
single age running
i'm 22 years older than the average
person who dies in this country and it's
been a pleasure
for my age i'm
practically number
hey everybody welcome to the podcast my
podcast the show where we go deep on a
really wide variety of stuff stuff that
i think matters including
health fitness nutrition what else
longevity
what it means to pursue a life of
meaning which are all subjects we're
privileged to explore today through the
lived experience of a centenarian
a human who has literally been walking
the earth for a full 100 years which is
of course
rare it's really unique and just an
amazing privilege to be able to talk to
him today his name is mike fremont mike
is a retired engineer turned climate
activist and athlete who in addition to
being pretty darn with it holds prepare
yourself get this just an absolute
slew of age group world records and
running including the fastest recorded
marathon for an 88 year old for a 90
year old and a 91 year old if i got that
right at the ripe young age of 96 mike
set the american one mile record for the
95 to 99 age group and as a lifelong
canoe racer at 99 he was the oldest
person to race the canoe national
championships and mike's still out there
every single day just getting after it
so
how does he do it what is mike's secret
well this conversation is my attempt to
extract his testimony and his counsel
for
younger generations on what he's learned
about life what he's learned about
longevity vitality
purpose
fitness setting world records and and
diet because for mike
it's kind of all about diet specifically
the whole food plant-based diet that he
adopted 30 years ago something he did in
the wake of receiving a colon cancer
diagnosis that he really credits as
fueling his training it's what keeps him
spry it's what informs his climate
activism and in his words really is the
thing that has allowed him to thrive
decades beyond social expectations
it's not often you get the opportunity
to spend time with a centenarian and i
really think our culture fails pretty
miserably when it comes to appreciating
our elders so i really loved having him
on the show
shout out to mike's running buddy elite
ultra marathoner and friend of the
podcast harvey lewis for
making this podcast happen i consider
mike a brand new friend and i'm just
really proud to share his voice with all
of you today so
please hit that subscribe button and uh
let's do it this is me
and mike fremont
well mike it's a pleasure to meet you
it's an honor to talk to you today it's
a a rare thing that
uh
anybody gets to sit down with somebody
who has experienced so much life as you
and i i i just can't wait to hear more
about your life
i guess the first obvious question is
how does it how are you doing like how
do you how do you feel what is it like
to be
a hundred
these believe it or not are the very
best years of my life
no question why is that
things that i've worked for and worked
on
have
blossomed out
i'm still here
i can still run so to speak
for my age i'm
practically number one
yeah
by sheer process of elimination but also
i mean it's amazing that you still get
out there you're still running you're so
engaged with life and
um i i have to imagine that's a big part
of the secret just being engaged with
life and and finding purpose in the
things that interest you
uh well
it turned out that i made a wise
decision
when i was faced with an operation
and i hold that
largely responsible
for all the
records
that i said in old age
no question in my mind absolutely it is
diet that has to determine
my existence my continued existence
and my beautiful health
so tell me more about that you were 70
when you were diagnosed with colon
cancer 69 so yeah
maybe explain that a little bit
uh
yeah i had a polyp
p-o-l-y-p
in one of my nether parts
and the uh
doctor i went to sent me to the
cleveland clinic for a proper diagnosis
and they put a television set
connection into me and so i could see
what was going on
and they said that this
tumor that they saw
had
metastasized
which means it had taken root in
different parts of my body
the lymphatic system
and that even if they took the tumor out
they would have to go after those
metastases
and at the time
i had
by that time received a book from my son
in california that i'll see
probably tomorrow yeah
who has sent me a book
called the cancer prevention diet
by michio kushi a japanese chap who
settled here
and was in beckett massachusetts with
his
entourage
and
i called him to ask him why he sent me
the book
he said you may need it someday
so of course i didn't read it
until i was diagnosed
at which point i devoured it
and uh i want cold turkey on what is now
known as a vegan diet
at that time it was a
macrobiotic
diet
i think it was even beginning to be
accepted a little bit by people in
california
sure
so so essentially for the last 30 years
you've been eating a very strict whole
100
100
no exceptions cold turkey and what
happened to so called you get the
diagnosis
excuse me from the cleveland clinic did
they want to uh
put you in chemotherapy or did you do
chemotherapy or what happened yeah
they said
if you're not operated on
you have three months to live
[Music]
that was the other side of the equation
i thought so i
decided
after reading the book i decided i would
try the diet
and i said i'll check with you guys from
time to time
which i didn't do
because i
two weeks
after going on a diet
i realized that
various things were happening to me that
i hadn't anticipated such as
arthritis in the back of my neck
arthritis in the shoulder arthritis
knees fingers
had disappeared no explanation
no problem
furthermore my hands and lips
used to be chapped from the time i was a
little kid
that disappeared wow it disappeared
the only thing i might have had
which by that time i was
old enough
to have outgrown
was asthma
which is what kept me out of the
military
or she kept me out of school for a month
once um
was this for so you were
you were born
i i i assume you were born in like 1922
exactly right so you would have been
prime candidate for world war ii exactly
yeah so
half of my class was in uniform at
college right
in uniform and they had they had their
uh
educational
uh
experience there too
and i regretted i couldn't be part of
them
anyway
that
diet
has so much going for it like i marvel
that
big business hasn't grabbed it
and run with it
after all these years
people used to look at me strangely when
i say
no i don't eat meat
no i don't drink milk
no eggs no eggs
yeah well it has i mean there is big
business now in that it is much more
widely
acceptable and adopted and there are
lots of companies making products for
this lifestyle but you are correct and
it is interesting so
so
your your arthritis started to disappear
you knew something was going on inside
you but did you have a sense that this
was helping with your cancer
uh
i'm no doctor and
i can't uh get into that science
but uh
these
several of these diseases that we have
are truly
associated with eating certain
meats and
uh what other categories there are
but you would so you had you had adopted
this diet and you were eating this way
for a couple years and then at some
point you had the tumor surgically
removed began to bleed again yeah
i knew i had to be operated for the
basic tumor
i was operated by a doctor in dayton
who'd been in the army he's been an army
doctor
who specialized in that kind of
operation
and he told marilyn
after the operation he looked in 35
places for metastasis
and found none
none
35 places
so what i had done by simply changing
diet
was to kill the metastases
that would possibly have killed me
i found out subsequently quite a bit
subsequently in a matter of fact a
matter of months ago
that
there are something like 52 000
people a year who die of colorectal
cancer 90 of them
die of the
metastases
90
yeah that's amazing and it and it never
after you had the tumor removed there
was no you were in remission and it
never came back
well
i feel that i can counsel actually
counsel people who have this particular
disease yeah you say try this right
right and uh and and where does the
running begin
running um
i was 36 i had three little children
and my first wife
and she died of a brain hemorrhage
when our daughter was two weeks old
and i was uh i had started a business a
year before
and i was all alone
and uh
decided i
was stressed
and i lived on a dam
and i used to run across that dam
which was leveled
right
every day after work
and it was very rewarding it was better
than two martinis
but not to be competitive at that time
no thought of it right
then someone said why don't you get in
the race and i said uh uh
me
uh like i'm 50 years old
36 years old or was it
but i kept running i enjoyed it and used
to go to the beach
whenever we went to the beach
which is not in cincinnati of course
right
so running was became a little part of
my life
and then they got me in a race
and i did okay
i didn't come in last uh-huh
then said were you gonna try for boston
i said i have to run a marathon first
so i ran a marathon
that didn't qualify for boston uh-huh
so i ran a few more marathons and i
qualified then i did my first boss and
and i thought wow
you can actually run
yeah
yeah so it's it's around 60 where you
start getting competitive though
as i understand is that correct
not really
i don't think i ever became competitive
actually until
i was 88
i ran a marathon when i was 88 and i got
first first
place
in history
in what they call the um
world
single age
running
category i brought you some sheets of
that to show you sure you hadn't seen
them yeah so so at 88 you set the single
age world record for the marathon
and then at 90 you do it again the
single age world record for the marathon
and at 90 you also set the single age
world record for the half marathon
and at 91 the single age world record
for the half marathon that's right so
you have
one two four
world records
and you have a whole slew of five-year
age group records going it's there's too
many to even keep i don't even realize
that at the time uh-huh
there's not much competition out there
there hasn't been
because people don't understand the
system how your system
works and contributes to being able to
do these things so talk about that i
want to hear more about
how to how to do this thing so maybe
explain how you do it like how are you
how are you able to not just run
marathons and half marathons in your
late 80s and over the course of your 90s
but also set world records like what is
the
secret to longevity here we talked about
diet but also what is your
fitness routine
the longevity part of it is
the interesting part i think
and the
japanese are credited
with uh living
six years longer on average than
americans
that's a huge amount yeah
but here i've already as i'm 22 years
older than the average person who dies
in this country right
and it's been a pleasure
and it's simply
simply because of what i eat which is
not that
specifically
precision
designed
to make me an expert i'm not an expert
on it i know what works for me
and i've never had any question about it
but i just don't do
bad things in eating mm-hmm uh what it
do tell me exactly what it is that you
eat like a day in the life of food for
you like what are your meals
well
tomorrow or today
i had some oatmeal
that had a few blueberries in the top of
it
and then some sweet glop or syrup or
something a little little teeny thing
and i had a cup that was about this high
filled with fruits
for actually with berries there's
strawberries and
and blackberries
and blueberries
and
one other thing might have been a piece
of mango or something
it was seven dollars at the motel which
is a very high price
welcome to los angeles it wouldn't be
high price if it was alcohol
and what would it do what would a lunch
and a dinner look like for you
oh
i might have something as prosaic as
a half a can
of uh black beans or kidney beans or
[Music]
garbanzo beans
with a little bit of
tamari
salty sauce with just a few drops of it
and then i put the other half away in
the ice box and knead it the next day
right so i try to get beans every day
and
i might do
some broccoli
uh flowers
which i use a little bit of catsup with
to make them taste like something yeah
okay so pretty pretty basic uh close to
their natural state
sorry to interrupt the flow we'll be
right back with more awesome but i want
to snag a moment to talk to you about
the importance of nutrition the thing is
most people i know actually already know
how to eat better and aspire to
incorporate more whole plants more
fruits vegetables seeds beans and
legumes into their daily routine sadly
however without the kitchen tools and
support very few end up sticking with it
so
because adopting a plant-based diet
transformed my life so profoundly and
because i want everybody to experience
some version of what i've experienced we
decided to tackle and solve this very
common problem the solution we've
devised i'm proud to say is the plant
power meal planner our affordable
all-in-one digital platform that sets
you up for nutrition excellence by
providing access to thousands of highly
customizable super delicious and easy to
prepare plant-based recipes everything
integrates with automatic grocery
delivery and you get access to our
amazing team of nutrition coaches seven
days a week and many other features to
learn more and to sign up visit
meals.richrol.com and right now for a
limited time we're offering 10 off an
annual membership when you use the promo
code rr health at checkout this is
life-changing stuff people for just a
dollar seventy a week literally the
price of a cup of coffee again that's
meals.richroll.com promo code rrhealth
for 10 off an annual membership all
right
let's get back to the show
so what about the fitness routine what
is the secret to how you've been able to
continue running into your 90s and now
at 100. i was able to retire at the age
of 88.
so low stress free time
stress also kills
and if you can keep your life from
distress as well as stress
you're very
fortunate but diet and stress are the
two things that can kill
definitely can kill
but
tell me tell me about your your daily
fitness routine and how you've been able
to stay active and and running like how
do you keep it up
well actually i i run in a place called
sharon woods which is a
county park uh
five and a half miles from where i live
and it has hills
and it has a
gravel path and has a
blacktop path all together
and one circle is five miles
and the same people come out there year
after year all the time you expect to
see them you make friends of them
i do that
my routine had been three times a week
monday
not monday uh sunday
tuesday and thursday
i would run 10 miles until i was 98.
yeah wow
and i just said it was taking too long
for me to run
miles with all the people i had grown to
know
over
how many years was it was about
you see
we set up a little
group
in nineteen
seventy
nine mm-hmm yeah
yeah it's
and 40 years yeah that's that's quite a
long time
10 miles three times a week
ten miles three times that was
30 miles 10 miles three times a week
and what is it like now uh it's five
miles
three times a week
and do you do any uh i know canoeing i
wanna talk about the canoeing but do you
do any other kind of exercises
uh up to this year
i've been a canoe racer
on a a lake that's three miles away
and
they refused to let the lake be used a
county park lake
by people who might drown
you know people self-propelled sure
canoes or
kayaks
they even kept roland mullin who was a
olympic champion three times
in canoe racing
in the olympics
they let him wouldn't let him
they were worried about him drowning
[Music]
[Laughter]
what we did was to
scare the park district
because their lawyers and their
insurance people had said don't don't
let people do that they'll drown and
they'll sue and
right you'll have to pay
but we said we we pay for these parks we
have a right to use them
so they finally say okay 2000
will open them up and they did
so i was one of the first guys out there
with my racing canoe
and another guy in an old canoe came up
to me and says
what kind of canoe is that and i
described it and i said you want to try
it and he said yeah
so we exchanged canoes and he tried it
the next day
he took his pickup truck and drove it to
western maryland
bought the same canoe and drove it back
the same day
oh wow
and he became your canoeing buddy
he became our canoeing buddy
and then we attracted another guy
because we're out there plugging away
and then i said you know
we had we ought to start a group here
he at the time was 13 years younger than
me mm-hmm
that was 2 000 so i was what uh
78
um yeah he was 13 years younger he was
65
i said you're going to be the tapioca of
this organization
he said what the hell is that
this is the temporary
acting
provisional
interim
orchestrator of coalition activities
there you go
that's quite a handle
it's a lot of pressure
and he said what should we call this
outfit
i said why don't we call it the epa
that's the elderly paddlers association
there you go
so we
attracted a few more we probably got
about
12
all together marilyn
there's one of them
who come out on
monday wednesday and friday
that's 7 30 in the morning
before the motorboats go out there
before it's uh
uh
uh early enough to be daylight i mean
late enough to be daylight
right and are you still doing that now
yeah you are well i haven't started the
season yet
it's been too cold but the epa lives
lives on oh yeah okay good
and where did you where did you meet uh
harvey obviously harvey lewis is our
connective tissue he introduced us
um i know that you guys are are really
good friends when did you meet harvey
i'm not sure
but it was uh
within the last four years
and uh i was very taken with him i
thought he this is
a tremendous athlete
and a tremendous person
and he asked me twice to speak to his
class his high school
class i said what are you teaching
he said well government and
operation of cities and that sort of
thing
it's a high school kids right
and so what i wanted to tell them and
this is about the diet and
uh
athletic stuff because that would be
what they might be interested in
harvey uh
asked me
every year if i want to run a
flying pig marathon yeah
5k or 10k
[Laughter]
i'm not up to a
marathon anymore
unless somebody were to
say well we'll give you thirty thousand
dollars
for charitable purposes
uh
if if they
said that i said i would say i will
train
for a year
to run a marathon at this age uh-huh if
you give me enough money to fund this or
that or the other yeah yeah yeah
nobody's taking me up on it i could see
that happening though has anybody run a
marathon at age 100 i don't think that
that's ever occurred i don't think so
i really don't think so yeah
i think i could
because i think uh
a marathon
the one i the one i i i
set the world record in
was not overly stressing mm-hmm
it wasn't
no i think i could have gone further
really
i would imagine somebody could put
together some funds that would go to
charity to see you train and do a
marathon
well it would compromise i would have to
make a major sacrifice in lifestyle i
think
yeah i would imagine it might be
possible maybe i'd find it wasn't
possible for me to do that but i would
only do that in
if i my training told me that i could
right
but you're doing like so recently you've
done 5ks with harvey so you're still
doing races just not marathons he runs
at my speed yeah
he's an amazing human being about harvey
so did you go and talk to the students
what did you tell them i told him about
global warming
and
sustainability
of the world on this planet
and the reason i
did that is i thought through
introducing
as best i can
the impact
of diet
which translates to agriculture in
general
not completely because
we have to grow cotton and we have to
grow
trees
and that
agriculture
at the time i was supposed to be
contributing agriculture and quotation
marks
supposed to be contributing
51
of the co2
the excess that we have
in the atmosphere
41
not 51
and we have to reduce that
and
somebody who understands it can help
inform the public and make
get the politics in such a ways to do
that
we have not been very effective doing
that now we haven't we should have been
much much more effective
by talking to you
so that other people can hear
is
an important move for me in my small way
and us we have a little
share we call it a think tank
of four people at home who meet once a
month
trying to get this word out
and we've done our own study over the
effect of
food
alone
in agriculture
of the total co2 equivalent which
includes some methane some no to earn
energy and water vapor to sma certain
extent
those are the greenhouse gases sure sure
sure yeah so so climate change
sustainability the impact of agriculture
on climate change and also the ability
to
be part of the solution by getting
people to change their diet this is
something that is
important to you you've been advocating
for this for a long time and i know that
you've put a lot of time and energy and
resources into restoring and improving
ohio's rivers and streams right you've
been active in
the restoration of of of the waterways
in ohio over the years well that was
before the uh global warming issue
uh-huh yeah
uh
i guess i
i was a canoe racer i've been a
canoeister 60 years right
i know how to run a canoe
in the
early days
uh
we worried about where we paddled and
it was degraded or there were dams in
the way or
all sorts of nasty things being done to
the waters
of the country
and they passed
in 1986
the national wild and scenic rivers act
as a national
thing
and the little miami river which goes
through cincinnati
was one of the first 27 rivers in the
whole country
designated to become a candidate to be a
member of the national wilds on santa
cruz river system
and so that gave
put a focus on the little miami river
which is a beautiful river and where i
used to practice before i practiced on
the lake
i was pretty far away and
the reason i gave it up for the lake is
because
it was not convenient
but i used to practice on that
the
state of ohio
had a friendly governor who happened at
the time to be a uh
a democrat
and his name was john gilligan
and uh
he was sympathetic to what we wanted to
do we wanted to protect ohio's rivers as
a matter of fact we had
set up an ohio river
ohio scenic river system a year
before the federal government did so
uh
the idea at least the idea that we had
was that the
the people who really cared about their
rivers should be members of a board of a
statewide river protection group
and that's what we started with
and we were able
through that
means to gather larger numbers of people
together get decisions made to protect
these rivers and
interestingly to me anyway
we decided that the american people have
a way of expressing
their
interest in things
is measured in dollars
and i think we're internationally known
for that yeah
yeah and we we decided that the little
miami river was bringing
unbelievable returns
to the villages along it
from economic returns
to the canoe liveries
from the fishing
from the swimming
from the property value appreciation of
having this beautiful stream go by that
the little children could play in
and we decided it was bringing in
to the public
a hundred thousand dollars a year every
year reliably
as well as employing these kids
who could hustle canoes and liveries
it would be hard job to
replace
and uh
that meant uh
10 million dollars a year for the 100
miles of that stream
100 miles of the little miami river
would bring in 10 million dollars a year
without just because it was there sure
so rather than appealing to somebody's
uh sensitivity to environmental issues
by focusing on the economic impact
and appealing to the incentives of
of that to keep the rivers clean that's
what moves the needle that's what
actually
exactly yeah
yeah
then we had a governor
whose name was bob taft
who was the son of
our grandson of william howard taft of
great
national fame sir
and i went to school with the
two taft guys
both gone now
and
test
a wife
hope
and he
bought
a place on the little miami river to
retire and after he was retired by the
voters
years ago
and she got really excited about water
quality and the
little miami river the upper 43 miles of
it it's 100 miles total
and they live in the upper 43.
and
with the taft money and all there was no
trouble to get
ohio state university which i had worked
with for 12 years
to understand the economics of the
little miami river
and she got
the guy who
was handed the job after the professor i
worked with retired in 2008.
brent sanchez and his name is
and they came out with a super super
economic study
which is
very simple you haven't really had a
chance to study it yet
they were bringing in something like 233
000 a year
year after year
instead of a hundred thousand dollars
per mile
per mile the river
just the economic value right so the
numbers bore it out that it's in
everyone's interest to keep this river
clean and that advocacy
led to that level of preservation yeah
that's beautiful people spend money on
it you know yeah the first time we
we
put somebody that it's got a trail along
it
and lots of people use that trail and it
goes through different counties and
everything
and
they can
estimate how much
you put a guy
on the trail excuse me you want to take
a survey
and see how you like the river and how
much you spend you spend on gas you
spend on motel you spend on a bicycle
you spend on
and not close
you spend on food
how much do you spend a day
we figured out that they spend
about 20 a day per person
and uh i don't know how that's changed i
haven't read this new study yet it just
came out right
but uh
it's going to be a national prize winner
of an analysis of how much rivers are
really worth right in dollars right
right right right yeah that's
really proud of that because we started
that thing
um
when you reflect back on your on your
life
what is it that you like the wisdom that
you accrue uh as somebody who's been
alive for a long time like what what is
the message that you would like to
impart to younger people about what is
important and what isn't
well
the conclusion i came to long long ago
was the
real satisfactions that people can get
in their lifetimes
and that they consist
in helping other people
[Music]
period
in whatever way
as much as you can
that brings real rewards
yeah
service
and uh
yes
we're all servants so we should be
it brings
the pleasures it's not the money
if you got money and you're happy good
luck
right
and and
so your service comes in the form of of
your environmental work
this uh focus on climate change
what would be another example of how you
channel that
service for others that has given your
life meaning
uh well i think this is my
profession as it
were a time i can spare and it's a lot
i read it's a list of books i brought
here today
i'm desperate to read these things the
latest one is is advertised in the new
york times uh
sunday
review of books
and it it talks about uh
sustainability
and i need that book i want to see it
and the four of us in our little
think tank
want to understand that
the sustainability issue is an enormous
issue
because there isn't any way
we can go from a population
of
close to 2 billion
to one that is close to 8 billion
in my lifetime
one in my last lesson my last time
i think it was about two and a half
billion when i
graduated
[Music]
from college 1943
and now it's eight billion yeah how do
you do this on a planet it's not getting
any bigger
you can't farm anymore you can't farm
enough we can't feed all the people now
it just won't work
we're finding it won't work
we're finding it in hunger we're finding
it in
wars because people get flooded out
because the temperature change is making
the ground
unavailable to produce food
the oceans are finding it
impossible to produce fish relatively
speaking here and there
it's totally serious
[Music]
so the sustainability factor is every
bit as important as the temperature
the um
[Music]
world uh
temperature rise
so you you're somebody who you're a
child of the depression
you lived through
world war ii as a young person
um
when you
kind of look back on your life and
reflect upon
uh your peers i mean we live in a
society where it is about high stress
it's about accumulation of material
things but most people by the time they
reach around 80 end up in in you know
facilitated living centers nursing homes
etc you've been able to opt out of that
so
aside from the service piece and the
diet like what are the other
secrets of longevity that you've relied
on that people should know more about
exercise
yeah
breaking world not necessarily related
to diet yeah
exercise
being of service
diet
what about friendships community
absolutely relationships talk a little
bit about that
absolutely
yeah call it love if you want
well
i guess i'm succeeding at that without
trying
became a hundred i got a box this big
birthday cards
wow that's amazing most people as they
get older they don't they have very few
friends but you have lots and lots of
friends
well you find you had friends and you
didn't realize it yeah
i even got a a
citation by the governor of ohio
i didn't vote for him ever
as a matter matter of fact
the best governor we ever had
married my third wife
and then he died okay
i don't know i'm very very i realize how
tremendously fortunate i happen to be
yeah
and it
seems like
it's been a simple process
no intellectual adapter
dangerous ventures
or anything but just grinding along and
doing the best you can
and i've been very happy about it
but staying engaged with life with other
human beings having having a sense of of
purpose right like
your connection to climate change issues
and sustainability
your love for running and canoeing and
exercising
i would imagine these are big
big pieces in what you know kind of gets
you excited and out of bed in the
morning still
well
we're all kind of limited in what we can
do because
we feel
many of us anyway there were under the
control of
the ultra-rich and corporations and
we threatened in every respect
when you come to think of it
and how you handle this because
the corporations you are the key to our
uh
financial success
but
i leave that for other people to work
for me yeah
well what is your you know your your
message to
like imagine there's a there's a lot of
younger people who are listening to this
they want the wisdom of somebody who has
you know lived a life like yours
service
friendships purpose
you know what else
do you want to say to those people about
how to live a fulfilling meaningful long
life
well i think
an approach to young men and a lot of
young women now
is
sports
and and there's a success of vegan
athletes is tremendous sir
all whole magazines are devoted to it
several times a year and i see it
it never used to be that way
and you get
kidded for
eating special and
who do you think you are and how yeah
and uh
that's why i had some fun talking to
harvey's class
[Laughter]
well harvey's such a great ambassador of
that as well so i imagine his students
already know that he's a plant-based
athlete they know that he runs these
crazy races but
probably receptive to what you had i
went uh
shopping with him at a whole foods
market in cincinnati when he was
getting supplies for his uh
uh appalachian trail oh appalachian
trail race
and his father would
carry it in their van
and cook for him when he came in and
he'd sleep in there and then he'd go off
the next day his father and me
yeah
hundreds of miles away
49 days
to go 2 000 plus miles yeah
the mere fact that a a human can do that
says that they understood the principles
of feeding and resting and
limits to your
output as well
and he's got to figure it out and see
it's beautiful
have you uh have you heard of the
uh the term blue zones the blue zones
people pockets of populations around the
world where people live the longest yeah
centenarians and they studied these
populations and they extracted from that
certain
tenets or principles
of lifestyle that all of these
communities shared
among them are
diets that are predominantly plant-based
they aren't exclusively plant-based but
most of these populations where where
they have the highest concentration of
people living to 100 and beyond are
eating mostly a plant-based diet but
they also
are are populations where
they're moving all the time they're not
going to the gym or running marathons
but they have seasonal yeah
movement-oriented lifestyles uh and
and they have rich
rich relationships within the community
so they have support and they have
connection
they're also tend to be relatively
faith-based in different ways like faith
is a big piece of it and this idea of
purpose like what in okinawa they call
ikigai like feeling like you have
a reason for your for your living and
and what i see in you is an example of
all of those principles and
it is admirable what they do
i haven't uh
been exposed to it i know that they
do exist i
read a little bit about them but
there's always some limit to what they
can do because of this or that or the
other thing but they do live longer
they are happy people
[Music]
and
maybe there are a lot of ideas that they
have that we could use if we
are smart enough to do to do so yeah
yeah yeah
but the fact that you didn't even kick
into your highest gear in running until
you were around 60 and that's when
you kind of really found your
competitive groove with all of this like
it's very inspiring because that's a
period of time where most people would
feel like it's time to slow down
and i in in your example that's where i
feel like you really started to get more
engaged with your life
well i think as
i was in business long enough to
understand that there's
a competition
that's normal to business in the united
states and other countries
and so there's a spirit of competition
that's the way you get things done
and uh
it's not totally
uh
compatible
with
the lifestyle you would
advocate you might say
that's something i don't know more about
yeah
but you said that now you feel like
you're having the best time of your life
[Music]
yes
well
we had a birthday party on the beach
in florida
i saw the video
there's a video on the internet of that
of your birthday party i have a
nephew who was
the mayor of uh vero beach
which is where we have relatives and
weary
and he called up somebody
who used to be manager of the
local newspaper
the vero beach press journal
and he came out on the beach to see me
on my birthday and took all his stuff
down
and i published it the next day and i
marilyn and i went around and fetched 10
copies of the newspapers so we could
send it to our families
and you're here in los angeles you have
children grandchildren and a great
granddaughter here that you have yet to
meet because of the pandemic is that
right i haven't met her because it's
been questionable whether one should fly
right
well you're here so you're going to have
a big family reunion
yeah we will we will so that's
uh
marilyn's sister lives in a
lake arrowhead
up the hill in san bernardino sure
and she's gonna
see us this afternoon
good
um
well i want to um
kind of end this on uh
on uh a note of of inspiration like
again going back to
looking over the course of your life
you've lived through
so many periods of of american history
and
you know now we're as you mentioned
tipping into
eight billion people on the planet like
when you reflect back over the course of
your life
like how do you feel about
the future of america and the future of
of the planet going forward
well
either we
face a period of really tremendous
suffering
massive suffering
or we get smart enough to
do some
important
laws
and work on them and understand them
so that we can continue to manage this
little bitty planet
we can't you can talk about going to
mars i don't know anybody be willing to
do that
who's going to write the newspaper
yeah sure let's let's save our planet in
the meantime rather than abandon it for
another
of course
i don't know there may be one out there
out of the billions or trillions of
planets that there are right
the fact that you have thrived on a on a
plant-based diet over these years you're
an incredible
example of
the health and robustness of eating this
way and the fact that you've set these
world records eating this way you're
early pioneer of this lifestyle i know
that you've
you're friends with a lot of the the
legendary doctors in the space neil
bernard and colin campbell and caldwell
esselstyn
um and i just i salute you for being an
ambassador and uh and and like uh uh
such a youthful energy
uh
exemplar of eating a plant-based diet
and being this incredible athlete along
the way
and i really do think that you maybe you
maybe we should try to see if you can
get that marathon in it's a wonderful
thing it's it's a quality of life issues
you're afraid
yeah if people are nice to you when you
get old
well it's a it's a privilege to be able
to speak to somebody who who has uh who
has a who has been around for a while
and has wisdom to in part well yeah i
have i've been there i've been through
this and i've been through that
and uh i'm fortunate
very fortunate that i survived
my father died of liver cancer
and he had six months of terrible pain
and he'd been an athlete he'd been
a gymnast when he was in college
diet was standard american yeah
but liver cancer i'm sure was caused by
diet
i'm sure of it right
and today we would have fixed him up
yeah
but he he died at the age of 69.
and uh
my mother died of a heart attack which
was standard
right he sort of expected when they're
in their 70s
could have probably prevented that if
i'd known then
would i know now sure
but your your blood work is good you're
healthy you're going to be around for a
while i hope so everything's good you
get you get you you go to the doctor you
get your checkups everything is a-okay
uh
yes
they called me and asked me to come in
to have a
regular test and i did and i passed it
with flying coach you did amazing
[Laughter]
are the doctors
surprised when you come in
or they know you now like this is just
mine well
it's only one or two and when you come
right down to it
yeah
um they they have to accept it because i
can challenge you right
too easily right
right right right well anyway thank you
for coming to talk to me today
you are you are an inspiration and uh it
it is amazing the fact that that
you changed your diet at 70. this is
probably
no question
it's actually
the high point
of what you may call my career
to be interviewed by you
who has interviewed
i got your volume too it's a gorgeous
thing oh you did good
good it weighs about 20 pounds
[Laughter]
you could do cruises where do you get
this photography like that and all those
people look so inspiring
[Laughter]
that's not my different part
no i think i think what you what you're
doing is incredibly inspiring and your
example
i think is very uplifting
to
everybody who would hear this or see
this
who's thinking about their future and
what that might look like as as we all
get older and you know again i've said
it many times over the course of our
conversation but the fact that you have
remained so uh not only active
um but
but really intentional in how you're
living your life
is i think a real inspiration to all of
us and so i guess
just in closing if there's any kind of
final thoughts or or wisdom that that
you would like to impart to anybody
who's listening to this well i'm
very grateful for this opportunity
my gang of four will be very pleased
that
i was able to express myself on this and
that subject that we
work on once a month normally
and that's a major impact i could have
is to reach other people with this
message
because i'm saying it works for me
big time
to be at least
22 years older than the average person
who dies
in america
[Music]
and i feel
that's not long enough yet
yeah
i think you got a lot of life
yeah so you're always welcome here and i
look forward to hanging out with you for
a little bit afterward we're done here
and
um i just appreciate you sir so thank
you and keep doing what you're doing i
think it's important and powerful like i
said and
just to be in a thriving example of a
plant-based diet it's a wonderful
wonderful thing
thank you yeah you're very welcome from
the bottom of my heart i thank you
right back at you my friend
[Music]
you